[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go figure
yes I think we did I'm like actually
scared that I made that claim because I
don't know what's actually out there of
like people that I actually desert IO
podcast too so I'm even scared for this
to show up on the vlog cuz now it was
like no no I took the challenge too so
you will represent everybody that I'm
gonna tell I'm much busier than James so
I think James has to do the rest
so this medium so I started doing flash
briefings because I found these guys
that are basically like the libsyn of
flash briefings yep where it takes like
one minute to get it up yep and then I
read your chapter in your book last
night and crushing it all about you're
calling it voice first are you good as
use that term for like flash briefings
are all voice that to me look I think
voice is kind of term I'm using for
podcasting and flash briefings and
Google and Apple home pod and like all
the stuff that's coming with voice it's
big pot is gonna do last briefings as
well oh yeah I mean homes Apple and
Google and Amazon all these people their
business is to create a platform then
let people build on top of it and then
make a percentage of the action no clue
could care less okay okay so let's see I
also want to ask you so before this
podcast I was I was very nervous yeah
Teli my friend like I'm really nervous
it
I just have to remember that you're just
a human being yes and you put on your
pants one leg at a time I've actually
put my parents to drugs at a time I jump
into my pants I wake up I grab my phone
I go take a poop I make sure nothing's
on fire in the world of my world you
know my biggest thing look when you're
when you're the CEO of a thing it's your
fault you're the last line of defense
and so that's the tough spot and the fun
spot and so really my morning is really
interesting right like it's funny I can
actually break down my morning the first
thought that runs through my mind is am
I tired like did I get the sleep that I
needed today to go hard and like the
good news is like that I'm in a good
place nine out of ten times and then the
one time that I'm not then I'm like oh I
hope that my workout today is gonna wake
me up or make me feel better so I love
that I work out now because whereas I
used to not have that and like struggle
through the first couple hours and then
my adrenaline would kick in now usually
it's very rare for me to like be tired
and go through a workout and not be
ready for today right but the biggest
thing I do is I check on fires I make
sure nothing happened in London don't
forget it's five or six hours ahead of
me so even when I wake up at six
they're already you know well into their
day and there could be a problem and so
and overnight in LA right you know if I
go to sleep at midnight it's still only
nine their clients are still doing
things so I make sure there's no
problems I'm rolling a bat on my lower
left back because I'm fixing my lower
left back muscle issues and tissue
quality and it's been a very weird you
know couple weeks for my team watching
me like do all sorts of weird things
with my back but it's really good I've
uh for everybody's watching right now
tissue quality I don't know if people
know this your brain protects you from
like your most inefficient physical
attributes and creates huge
inefficiencies by protecting you and
I've realized how limited I was in my
rotation and bending and stress
and and it's not about you know yoga and
massages this is like real [ __ ]
tissue work like you got to really like
do it but it's been amazing and I'm
getting I've had a bad back for like 25
years and I'm like this close I'm like
I'm the final pieces right now which is
why I'm like I'm taking this huge piece
of wood right it's a half a baseball
back and like ramming it into my back
like ramming my back
no my my trainer Jordan we roll we roll
on a hard ball a lacrosse ball we have a
we have a stick this is not something he
recommends this is just I know this is
working because I'm beating up the
muscle like I can feel what's happening
you know I it's amazing how long it
takes you to reach for your phone and
like you stay in bed and your tweets are
you up immediately if I didn't have to
wake up early I'd be naturally a night
person
I grab the phone and I'm usually I never
lay in bed like I'm up
I grab the phone I go in a drink of
water go to the bathroom like like it's
like I'm usually like after I wake up
I'm in I'm out of bed within seconds
usually because I try to maximize sleep
so like I've got to go like I've gone to
the extreme of like I've got to work out
in four minutes like I've got to go to
the bathroom
like brush my teeth put on gym clothes
and get down stair like I keep it tight
so I would naturally be a night person I
like to get work done at like midnight 1
2 3 I don't like the morning I wake up
wait earlier than I used to
there was a time where I was such an
extreme you night person building wine
library I go to sleep at 3 or 4 and not
get into wine library until 11:00
that happened for like a year that's how
extreme I went but now I get up at 6 or
7 and that's how I roll okay maybe the
people even knew don't that we really
know you because
you know you're everywhere yeah I really
feel like we do know you do some degree
yes what what would we be surprised to
know about you well you know nothing
about my fam you don't know anything
about my family life I'm very sure no I
mean like you know nothing about my kids
or my wife or I spend very little on
that we keep that private so you guys
don't know that part of me and I think
the part that most I think the part that
most people don't know about me is all
of you anybody that likes or dislikes me
but more likes me has to keep a
percentage to themselves to keep them
protected from me not letting them down
right when somebody admires are like
somebody there's a protective mechanism
that everyone has which is man I really
hope he's like that in real life right
so it's been really really bad and what
about you that happened right did you
when you first started working here
there was a party of you're like oh I
hope he's that real in real life like
like right like you know like and you
didn't have the same dynamic cuz I was
in a different place so nonetheless like
I think the biggest thing that people
don't know about me is that I think I'm
even nicer in real life then I project
right cuz you see the real stuff that I
can't show where I'm being really nice
but you it's inappropriate for me to
show it because I mean look look make it
look the other person look a little
weird perfectly this question that I've
dying to ask you or just I want to
mention because like it really I saw
this the other day where you said that
like you're in this unique position
where you have like cross the chasm into
like being cool for the younger people
yes a 17 year old son like is you know
completely every word you said you said
if I can achieve making self-awareness
and patience and gratitude and empathy
cool characteristics of an alpha male I
will have made a real impact and I
thought
like for all the moms and dads that are
probably so mad at you changing their
minds about college yes like that
you probably get just as many love
letters or more after a statement like
that but then but then I'm like can we
really do that and what would it take to
really make those things cool without it
just being like a good quote you know
what I mean yeah I mean I think I'm
doing it like I you know with me my
quotes come after I've already done
something I would have never had the
audacity to say something that ludicrous
if I hadn't started seeing it actually
start to happen yeah I mean it's it is
amazing like I I really think it's very
special when somebody comes along and is
a great communicator and can move
people's minds and does it for good I
mean because some do it for good some do
it for bad and some never realize they
can do it you know why do you you know
think about how excited I am about both
your 17 year old son and you for your 17
year old son I'm gonna create a new
paradigm of cool and hopefully that will
work and for you like I inspired you to
do and now your fight and now you're
finding out something that you're doing
that you enjoy and you may be good at
that's incredible yeah it's cool listen
I I talk about it as if it's not even me
living it because it's almost too heavy
for me to like I I'm being serious right
now I try not to overthink it because it
becomes a little daunting if you realize
you're sitting on a superpower right so
I try to like take it for what it is I
try to make my you know the truth is I
actually think it's a bigger indication
of my parents and my environment that it
is on me so I don't get big-headed about
it I know my intent is do the best I can
I don't feel daunted by the
responsibility I don't feel like it's my
I don't think I'm that special then I
have to change the world what I'm more
than interested in trying it would get
kind of like scary or I don't know maybe
feel like a burden and you say that I
mean and you teach us to like really we
just should care a care immensely about
everything but not but not give a crap
about what people say but I'm wondering
like don't you don't you ever get your
feelings hurt like I get my friend I got
it I get my feelings hurt every day I
get my feelings hurt every day in like a
fake way like I'm a human I'm just not
very emotional when it comes to this
because I understand the score I'm
unbelievably emotional I'm completely
unemotional like I have I think I'm this
great balance that's coming from extreme
characteristics so anytime een you know
I mean there was a there was a
engagement I had today on Twitter where
two guys in Europe or somewhere not in
the u.s. guy I kind of quickly glanced
who I think were from the advertising
industry we're making fun of me like one
of them put a picture of me where it
says hustle your [ __ ] face off and he
said something degree of like this is an
actual quote like can you [ __ ]
believe this guy and his buddy
or a similar thinking guy jumped in and
said like or and I think he said try to
find a quote that's more ludicrous than
this kind of thing and then his buddy
found one but I don't think that was a
real quote cuz the other one was real
but just took a picture of me and put
some ridiculous quote that I think I did
say like bottom line is they were
bantering I jump in because my feelings
are hurt because I don't know I like I
want these two guys to like me not think
I'm a douchebag
I reply with with my true feeling which
is like yo guys can you stop creating
ammo for my friends to make fun of me
with and I wish you good health and like
I hope we get to share a glass of wine
cuz I noticed one guys from Australia I
like Australian wines it was interesting
the other guy one of the guys I mean and
then I got to the office I don't see if
the other guys engaged one guy jumped in
and said Touche or fair enough like if
you're ever in Australia let's grab that
glass I loved it because like it's less
than my feelings are hurt it's that I
respect everybody else's opinions no
matter who they are even within my own
success like I think I'm gonna be all
time yet I don't believe that your or
your seventeen-year-old sons
or those two guys's opinions are any
less valuable than mine I just think my
ultimate superpower is empathy at the
highest level I think I'm so empathetic
that it that everything else I am is
almost secondary even though I have a
lot of other strong characteristics
strengths and weaknesses so of course my
feelings are hurt because I'm so
empathetic yet I'm so self-aware and
confident that it's not able to fully
penetrate and become a negative I think
it becomes a positive because I know how
to calibrate the pushback or the
name-calling
yes I mean great circumstance right I
lost a lot as a kid I didn't speak the
language we had no money I wasn't a
great athlete I was a terrible student
I've lived my first 18 years of my life
as a [ __ ] loser
which made the next [ __ ] hundred
years super easy because I wasn't scared
of losing a lot of kids are coddled /
loved eighth place trophies and / love
to actually believe that's not true
let me start again a lot of people are
coddled a lot of people are eighth place
trophies a lot of people didn't deal
with adversity because they figured out
how to run the school model and were
straight-a students gifted with talent
and sports and so they were winning
their first 18 years so when they go
into real life with inevitable losses
especially for somebody who like pander
to the system which means they then go
work in a corporation where they have no
control and merit doesn't ride you know
I'm the reverse yes I was super and that
part has never gone away I was popular
for you know I have charisma so that's
always good I was popular because I'm
super nice like nice has been you know
over the last week or two I have started
pushing kindness and nice it's funny you
know like I feel like almost just like I
figured out my back was hurt after I
figured my abductor was hurt and my knee
and my neck and like my shoulder I feel
like I'm just going through my life and
discovering wait a min
it's not just hustle wait a minute it's
not just sales wait a minute it's not
just empathy like and I feel like
somewhere literally within the last 10
days I'm like huh
kindness is probably a real big reason
this is all working out for me and so in
school my kindness was amazing because I
was so self confident that I wasn't
willing to make fun of kids when that's
what the cool kids did and that in a
weird way over time made me quite
popular with a lot of people I think
kindness is something that I will
continue to tap into this year this
would be the year of kindness and my
content I can feel it and I'm excited
about that because self-awareness and
gratitude and work ethic and honor I
think is something that an alpha male
can kind of like get there to kindness
being sweet being a sweetheart it's just
not necessarily the thing that I think
people naturally gravitate towards and
it's funny my public persona aka when I
do interviews and speeches
I wouldn't say is filled with kindness
I'm my most combative and competitive
it's that my real life is so filled with
kindness and sweetness and I think it's
gonna be interesting to see how I tap
into this and how I articulate it and
it's funny because the other challenger
James Altucher when he came on the show
I asked him like when you know have you
had situations where you've interviewed
people who are you know winners or
they're these big guys who are really
like jerks and he said you know not
really I'd 1 or 2 he said but the truth
is people don't get that far
usually by the super juries and
definitely and definitely not people who
are are playing in a game that is based
on merit like entrepreneurship right
like like it's a little bit easier
navigate through corporate which is a
lot of what we're seeing now in the
world because you can be protected
because the market isn't fair its hedged
by the tastemakers and the gatekeepers
but like the the more entrepreneurial
the more fair it is to James's point the
more likely you have to be a decent
person and definitely if you want to
build something really big for the long
haul like I'm trying to build an
absolute business empire and be admired
and like that is a that is a very
zero-sum game like either you are kind
and talented or you're not who would it
mean the most to you besides your
parents and your kids and everybody who
would it mean the most for you to be
admired by I mean like anyone
specifically that like you've got filed
away yes yeah probably Brandon Warnecke
he runs Wine Library is my best friend
to me to me it's very simple I want to
be admired by the people that know me
the best because they actually know the
truth like it's super more important to
me that Tyler and Tyler who's sitting
across from me right now my admin and
one of the guys who's on my content team
who film's me often it's much more
important to me that they blindly think
I'm the best then an employee at Vayner
that's not interacting with me more than
once or twice a year because they know
and I was watching you walk through your
office and all those I guess hundreds of
employees and I thought because you are
your brand and because you are such a
strong brand and because people
gravitate to you I'm sure that's one of
the big selling points that they want to
come and work for you but not everybody
can get that access to you so I'm I bet
that's a huge challenge for you to
figure out how you're gonna divvy up
Gary
yeah yes isn't all those people yes and
no I think I think that a lot of them
actually want to just work at a great
agency and haven't gotten into donees
there are people that are even weirdly a
not oblivious but really don't know the
extent of what's happening out there
with my life in that realm and that's
great because I'll be honest with you I
associate much more to Gary Vaynerchuk
the CEO Boehner axe vaynermedia than I
do as Gary Vee
I associate more to being Gary
Vaynerchuk the guy behind the strategy
of Gary B than Gary B and in look Gary
B's me like it's it's it's my energy
when I'm trying to talk to the world but
most of my life is spent not talking to
the world and and I do the best I can I
mean I think that's just important as a
CEO let alone as a personality I think
the people that are most bought into me
fans get their way into spending time
with me because they can't hold out
right they asked for the meeting they
hover around they hang out so or some
just kind of wait and wait for their
moment but uh it's again it's not
something I kill myself with the level
of service and care and love that I give
to the people who are in my never bit
yeah but I am not I'm not I'm not niche
down I do know the value of it I wish so
badly that I could just like find a
niche do you think that enough heart
telling lawyers your niches you might
I'm not me my niche is that it's me and
my perspective in my efforts and me
there's nothing more niche than being
the human being
you